[Music]
famously navikev said or infamously
perhaps that's now synonym for that too
said there is only one school of writing
that of talent and it's axiomatic that
you can't teach talent course econ but
what you can do is instill certain
principles and the avoidance of ugly
repetition is very important repetition
has its uses and anything is better than
trying to avoid repetition through what
they call elegant variation this is an
example from a biography of Lincoln
while in Chicago he appeared to back
concessions to the south in in New York
he scene seemed to support you know when
deeds there's no point in using a
different word when there's no change in
meaning and it that's just something
that the writer was taught when they
were 12 never to use a word twice in a
sentence and they've become terrorized
by that and then addicted to a new
ingenuity where you you avoid it but I'm
talking more about sounds and rhythms
the navicomp novel we know of as
invitation to a beheading was originally
called not for very long
invitation to an execution now as
navikev said of course I avoided the
repetition of the suffix so chose to
call it invitation to a beheading rather
invitation to an execution which is sort
of rhythmically ugly you've got to think
about the bits of the word as well as
the word in its totality avoiding
repetition of prefixes and suffixes as
well as Rhymes and half rhymes
unintentional alliteration it
century can be achieved by anyone simply
by using a dictionary and a thesaurus
people think thesaurus is there so you
can look up a fancy word for big or a
fancy word for long that's not what a
thesaurus is for in my view the sources
you come to a point in a sentence and
it's usually towards the end of a
sentence where you're unhappy with the
word you've chosen not because of its
meaning but because of its rhythm and
you may want a mono syllable for this
concept or you may want to try syllable
so you look in the supersaurus you find
a simile that has the right number you
know for the whole whole sentence to
maintain its rhythmical integrity and
you just do that by by going to your
thesaurus and also going to your
dictionary do not use words against
their derivation for example dilapidate
it's fine to talk about a dilapidated
building but not fine to talk about a
dilapidated hedge because dilapidate
comes from lapis which means stone so
you know really careful writer will make
sure that they're not doing and not
visiting and indecorum on the on the
words derivation it's very
labor-intensive and it takes a long time
to sometimes to get your sentence right
rhythmically and and to clear the main
words in it from misuse but and all your
winning is the respect of other serious
writers but I think that's any amount of
effort is worth it for that and it's
easy enough to find alternatives without
committing the dreadful sin of
elegant variation and it just involves
you in looking at reference books for a
couple of minutes and I look in the
dictionary I check words in the
dictionary a dozen times a day at least
and you find out very strange and
interesting things and for instance that
Widow originally meant just empty it's
an adjective meaning it empty now that
that's part of your when you'd look up a
word in the dictionary you own it in a
way you didn't before you know what it
comes from and you know its exact
meaning and whenever I do that when I do
it all the time
it's as if you feel a gray cell being
born in your head little addition to
your store of knowledge and while all
your the other cells are dying in a kind
of genocide of the aging process you can
restore it and that's what it feels like
and it's it it fortifies you
[Music]